it's likely the most policed street in
the country but while the nation was
forced into a strict lockdown it seems
those writing the rules may have been
breaking them in close proximity to
those tasked with enforcing them
a former chief superintendent for the
metropolitan police describes the level
of surveillance at downing street and is
in disbelief people weren't fined at the
time i'd be flabbergasted if the police
didn't have the evidence already i
worked at uh in parliament
it's the most cctv place in the country
and you'd expect that you know we've got
our parliament we've got our mps we've
got the prime minister there you have
banks of cctv you would see absolutely
everything that's going on
in a sign of how seriously this is now
being taken by scotland yard
deputy assistant commissioner jane
connors the forces lead for covert
enforcement will oversee the
investigation into what happened
dane cressida dick says the decision to
act was triggered by information passed
to the force from the cabinet office as
well as the judgment of her own officers
sky news understands the metropolitan
police will not rely on the sue grey
report and will start its own criminal
investigation from scratch
but amid claims some of its own officers
may have witnessed these downing street
events or parties some are questioning
if another force entirely should be
carrying out this investigation
the investigation will be complex
involving several different events and
dozens of witnesses but it's no longer
an internal inquiry
this time number 10 staffers will be
interviewed by a police officer under
caution
perhaps even the prime minister himself
it's likely to be weeks not days before
scotland yard reveals its findings it
should have started months and months
ago and i think most of the public are
quite incredulous that it didn't start
months ago and there has been a delay
already of many months
breaching covert rules is a minor crime
and issuing a fine retrospectively is
rare but 120 000 people had to pay one
of these fixed penalty notices
the far greater cost to the government
is the potential loss of public trust
sally lockwood's sky news scotland yard